[Music]
welcome back to CBS this morning for
almost four decades Admiral William
McRaven served as a Navy SEAL he oversaw
his you're heard Knorr say the raid on
Osama bin Laden he ended his career as
commander of all United States special
operations forces
McRaven reflected on his SEAL training
in his 2014 address to the University of
Texas graduates the video has nearly 25
million views online it starts with the
importance of a simple test if you can't
do the little things right you'll never
be able to do the big things right and
if by chance you have a miserable day
you will come home to a bed that is made
that you made and a made bed gives you
encouragement that tomorrow will be
better so if you want to change the
world start off by making your bed ever
McRaven wrote a book based on that
speech it is called make your bed little
things that can change your life and
maybe the world is now Chancellor the
University of Texas System Admiral good
morning
all right good renovator sort of the
elephant in the room everywhere and
today is what happened yesterday I mean
you lead a great institution you were
part of a great institution in the US
military you're a patriot just give us a
sense when you listen to what said
yesterday how it made you feel and what
do you think it says well obviously it's
very concerning and and I'm probably a
little biased because I know Jim Comey
not well I mean we're not the best best
of friends but I've spent a lot of time
with him over the last couple of years
fact he was just at the University of
Texas at Austin about a month or so ago
and gave a great presentation to the
students so I can tell you I trust Jim
Comey implicitly I do not know the
president so it's not a fair calculation
but but again it's unfortunate that we
the American people even have to kind of
go through that question implicitly you
think you're saying that you don't
believe he would lie I do not believe he
would lie now we can said watching it
for you yesterday it was difficult yeah
it was difficult because again this is a
this isn't necessarily about the FBI and
it's not about the president this is
about the United States of America and
what we value and what is important to
us and and I think it's important to get
to the bottom of this
and I'm glad to see Bob Muller who I
dunno well is is going to be trying to
do it all right when you think about all
of this the Russian probe as you just
said it's a serious issue and it's
essential that we get to the bottom of
it and get all the facts out in bomb ala
has that challenge absolutely and again
I think nobody is better positioned to
do this than former director Bob Muller
one he understands how the process works
he is also a man of incredible integrity
and he will get to the bottom of it
speaking of integrity yeah which I know
you have have led your life with and
this book is not just about making your
bed you know I know that's the title but
it's the small things that can lead I
think to a life of value and integrity
where did you come up with those 10
things well of course it was part of the
speech as was raised in the in the clip
but the interesting thing about it was
as I was writing the speech about
Wednesday before I was scheduled to give
the speech on on Saturday I had writer's
block and the speech I was working on
just wasn't working and my wife god
bless her when I came to her and I'm a
little bit of a panic and she says look
write about something you know and I
said well I've been a Navy SEAL my whole
life
I don't know that students are going to
want to hear about being a Navy SEAL and
she said write about something you know
so I did I took seal training which
really is is kind of life in about six
months you learn everything I think you
need to learn in that six months you
learn how to fail you learn how to be
your best in your darkest moments you
learn the importance of making your bed
so I took those lessons from seal
training and put them into the speech
and then it's great Admiral we could say
that George Ann came through for you one
more time and she always does but one of
my favorite chapters is never quit
because in life always puts you in
situations where quitting will seem the
easy thing to do you said but quitting
is never easy and just when you think
you can't go on you really can well the
fact the matter is I'm convinced and I
think again it's one of the things you
learn in SEAL training is when you think
you have hit the wall when you think you
cannot go any further
the instructors show you that you can
they push you even harder and and the
folks that succeed the folks that make
it through SEAL training realize that
there's always something left in the
tank you can always continue on you say
if you want to change the world start
singing when
up to your neck and mud well and this is
in seal training in the middle of what
we referred to as hell week we go down
to the mud flats and at one point in
time we were all in there the
instructors were trying to get us to
quit and there were a bunch of kids were
getting ready to quit and and one
student started singing and the point
was it was a little bit about the power
of hope we realized that if he could
sing when he was up to his neck in mud
maybe we could sing too and we did and
before long we came together as a as a
group in the conversation I've had about
this that speech it puts his number of
times you said that it's not always the
people you expect to pass right now
they're very small few who passed the
test and get on become seals and they
don't look like and they're not always
the one when you look at the beginning
you would expect to pass well we had a
group you know again there's all sorts
of shapes and sizes come in the seal
training I think this is the misnomer
everybody expects all seals to be you
know six foot to 210 pounds bulging with
muscles and in fact most of the guys who
make it through are smaller they're wiry
but we had a group we referred to as the
Munchkin crew based on the pod there
were the small guys and and they were
remarkable they were some of the best
swimmers the best runners we had and you
learn very quickly that it really isn't
about as we used to say the size of your
flippers because they had small little
feet it wasn't the size your flippers it
was a size your heart that mattered
would you mind removing your shirt so we
can see is that a no okay let's go back
to the title of the book making your bed
because Nora said Gail did you make your
bed this morning no did you Charlie make
your bed this no no so I said good for
you Nora cuz she did in your book you
said Saddam Hussein didn't make his baby
but like this bad boy does not make you
a bad person I was asked that question
earlier just because you don't make your
bed does not make you Saddam Hussein is
even when you were injured when you
could recover the first thing you did
was make your bed I did and I think this
is you know it was instilled to me and
still to me at a young age it was
reinstalled in me when I got the SEAL
training kind of the importance of this
little task every morning I might get a
little task it helps you do the next
task and the next task and it also
reaffirms the fact that little things
matter but the most important thing you
say here don't quit don't know quickly
yeah never quit and and I think this is
true regardless if this isn't about SEAL
training this is about life I see great
students going through the University of
Texas System I will tell you they have
just the same amount of strain
and and and personal courage and
dedication to get through the world of
academia which is tough today thank you
so much for coming my pleasure thank you
admiral boorda and thank you and make
your bed is on sale now